la revue de presse
avec vous hélène frade bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline à la une de la
presse internationale la guerre des
nerfs autour de l'ukraine où aucun signe
de désescalade ne se manifeste malgré
l'intensification des efforts
diplomatiques chaque jour ou presque la
presse internationale fait état de
discussions de la dernière chance à
l'image de journal britannique les aie
qui évoque ce matin d'ultimes efforts
diplomatiques pour stopper la guerre en
europe et comme chaque jour ou presque
le kremlin souffle le chaud et le froid
le journal russe kommersant faisant état
de discussions hier entre vladimir
poutine et ses ministres des affaires
étrangères et de la défense discussions
à l'issue desquels le président russe
pauline aurait décidé je cite ni de la
paix ni de la guerre à quoi joue le
président russe talent est encore et
toujours la question à voir avec ce
dessin de brian adcock port d
independence ou vladimir poutine hésite
entre eux et inde or et rallumer les
appareils de réanimation de l'apec dans
celui de motorland pour le times on ne
sait pas non plus si le hockeyeur
poutine de l'équipe de russie va fauché
pour de bon ou non la patineuse
ukrainienne avec son bateau à propos
précisément de sports de glace à la
russe beaucoup de réaction ce matin
après l'autorisation accordée par le
tribunal arbitral du sport à la
patineuse russe qu'on voit derrière vous
qui s'appelle camille navale ieva
autorisation de continuer à participer
aux jo de pékin malgré un contrôle
antidopage positif et au mois de
décembre une semaine après avoir
décroché la médaille d'or dans la
compétition par équipes la jeune
patineuse de 15 ans a également été
autorisée donc à s'aligner sur l'épreuve
individuelle féminine d'aujourd'hui une
autorisation accordée en raison de son
nom de son jeune âge qui implique des
règles de preuve spécifiques et des
sanctions allégé mais qui ulcère
néanmoins de délits telegraph qui
annoncent même on le voit la mort des
jeux olympiques plus nuancée de
gardienne reconnaît que camila vallejo
et sans doute déjà l'une des plus
grandes patineuse de l'histoire et qu'il
est peu probable qu'elle est se soit
procuré elle même une substance
interdite mais le quotidien voit tout de
même dans cette affaire un pass 3 de
plus accordé à la russie par les
instances internationales du sport or
interpelle le guardian sans véritable
incitation à se réformer sans crainte
d'être expulsé définitivement du sport
international comment la russie pourrait
elle se décider à changer et puisqu'on
parle gio et patinage artistique pauline
impossible de ne pas mentionner la
médaille d'or décrochée par les français
y gabriela papadakis et guillaume
décison en danse artistique
goldeneye salue l'équipe une jolie
référence au film goldeneye ou james
bund pauline est chargé de retrouver le
goldeneye le satellite russe volés par
des mercenaires on sait ce qu'on appelle
une transition dont on va reparler des
jo dans un instant à la une également
l'acquittement en appel hier au pakistan
hélène d'un jeune homme condamné à la
prison à vie pour crime d'honneur
d'après le quotidien pakistanais dawn ou
ahmad waseem avait fièrement reconnu
avoir étranglé sa soeur une vedette des
réseaux sociaux en raison du
comportement intolérable de celle ci je
le cite un assassinat pour lequel il a
donc finalement été totalement acquitté
par un tribunal qui as probablement tenu
compte du pardon accordé au jeune homme
par ses parents le journal donne qui
exprime son émotion également au
lendemain d'une autre affaire la
lapidation révélée dimanche par les
autorités pakistanaises d'un malade
mental lapidé à mort par une foule
l'accusant d'avoir brûlé un coran un
nouveau cas de violences liées au
blasphème dans laquelle le journal voit
la manifestation d'une colère est d'une
toxicité nourri par une idéologie
erronée
récit rétrograde attisée par laitages
site alors que son pays est frappé de
plein fouet par la crise du coc vides et
des matières premières le premier
ministre pakistanais tentent quant à lui
de revenir dans les bonnes grâces
occidentales notamment françaises selon
le figaro auquel imran khan a accordé un
long entretien où il revient notamment
sur la prise de pouvoir des talibans en
afghanistan et oui il prévient je le
cite qu'il y a une limite à ce que des
pressions étrangères peuvent accomplir
sur leurs gouvernements un bon pour
terminer hélène de ce rapport publié
hier par l'académie française sur l'
usage croissant du franglais la
multiplication des anglicismes dans la
communication institutionnelle
si je vous dis roaming danois ou pick up
station savez-vous exactement de quoi je
parle pauline beaucoup de français en
tout cas ne le savent pas et c'est bien
ce qui inquiète les immortels le fait
que ce sabir franco-anglais aggrave la
fracture sociale et générationnelle
habitants de la start up nation ou pas
qui est imé qui est out les académiciens
met en garde contre l'insécurité
linguistique grandissante et le figaro
se demande lui comment exprimer cette
incompréhension est ce malaise sans
passer pour un imbécile pardon un boomer
en anglais tout nu se dit naked the
guardian rapporte que le patron de la
royal air force l'armée de l'air
britannique a été contraint à la
démission pour cette pro s'être promener
tout nu dans son jardin se promener chez
soi en tenue d'adam n'a a priori rien de
répréhensible me dire oui mais le
problème semble-t-il c'est que ses
voisins se sont plaints publiquement de
voir andrew turner dans le plus simple
appareil sochaux qui a semé vous me
l'enlever de la bouche et j'allais le
dire vous m'avez couper ma blague merci
beaucoup hélène à tous